je suis un disciple de nostradamus et je
vais vous faire les prévisions 92 accord
montre moi votre main ok vous êtes dans
un jeu de mariée au déficit sera pas
difficile
vous êtes mariés depuis une bonne
trentaine d'années un homme ça sinon
vous êtes fumeur
ouais jarlet une armée alors donc je
vois vous êtes une femme de couleur
oui de ce côté là pas de changement 1 7
petits enfants cinq garçons deux filles
oui mais quatre garçons non soyez pas de
mauvaise foi est ce qu'on pourra pas le
faire vous avez à mon avis de cheveux
crépus sexuellement ça va bien un peu la
routine
oui ça peut aller c'est pas non plus
gros doigts et un travail pas de
changement je veux qu'on fasse
sexuellement
monsieur ait tendance à être un petit
peu rapide ah ouais ça je dirais pas
survivre votre votre mari qui enclins à
avoir des aventures comme à main c'est
le seul problème une croyance
à mon avis il va régulièrement voir des
professionnels du genre à coucher le
premier soir finale merci matinale
pardon on est pas très fidèle aussi à je
vois une aventure ah ben je vous ai de
la chance et moi je la vois pas et vous
avez eu des expériences homosexuelles
les tendances un petit peu non non non
jamais ça va venir
ah bon vous avez beaucoup apprendre
toujours la prendre aussi l apprendre
vous aimez la [ __ ]
oui avec une jeune fille blonde qui
était serveuse également anna je vois
serveuse blonde vous voulez nous excuser
il vous trompe avec un homme de couleur
à bala si charmant à mon avis c'est un
amour de vacances ça ne va pas durer
[ __ ] vaginale à ça si vous le dis à
vous avez des tendances homosexuelles
donc non non non vous n'êtes plus
homosexuels aient jamais été homosexuel
vous êtes plutôt vaginale vous aimez ça
une seule chose avec laquelle vous
n'êtes pas en accord ses les tendances
homosexuelles
sinon j'étais toujours dans le ton si
l'on faisait dans le temps mais ça va
vous arriver
oui vous allez vous faire bouger le cul
très prochainement et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux